and republican congresswoman nicole
maliotaka saw the crisis at the border
firsthand this weekend and she
joins us now congresswoman what did you
see
um you were our eyes and ears for the
weekend what did you see
yeah we went down to the border we
visited a processing facility we also
visited the donna facility where there
are housing
migrant children and some families
completely overcrowded 250 at capacity
and they had 4 000 individuals at this
particular site you saw children
sleeping on top of each other
practically and it was very
unsafe i think condition simply because
they are not providing covet tests
and they don't know who is infected and
many said that they did have fevers
but i have to tell you that the real
issue here is that the president has
turned over
the borders to the cartels the smugglers
and cartels are making billions
billions of dollars profiting off
smuggling individuals and the president
has incentivized
this and he has reversed those policies
put in place by president trump
that were working there was an agreement
with guatemala with mexico with honduras
and they were stemming the flow of the
illegal migration but now
it's completely out of control and at
the current rate we're talking about 175
000 individuals a month i mean with by
mid july
in this year alone there will be more
people crossing our border illegally
than reside in joe biden's home state of
delaware or the vice president's
home city of san francisco yeah
congressman when you talk about 175
000 they're saying 19 000 unaccompanied
minors that could be as high as 30
000 by some accounts when you hear the
president say
things like he wants to revamp these uh
these
border crossing areas and he wants to
put more
technology along the border is he
missing the big picture when you think
the border wall
is the centerpiece of all of that
enforcement and when you stop building
the border wall and you watch these
migrants come through
that's a that's a significant problem
well that's part of it certainly the
infrastructure but also he needs to
untie the hands of custom and border
protection they cannot do their job they
don't have the resources right now
because
as and it's all part of a plan by the
cartels as they are sending
uh hundreds of thousands of individuals
you know they're distracting
the cbp who are now processing asylum
applications which by the way less than
10
are actually legitimate claims they are
you know babysitting the children at the
migrant facilities
and and and meanwhile the poorest parts
of our border
are wide open and that's where the
nefarious stuff is happening drug
smuggling
gun trafficking individuals who have
been previously convicted of crimes and
deported or entering
you you saw the news reports about even
people on the fbi terror
watch list are crossing our border sex
offenders are crossing the border and
that's just who they were able to find
right
so we they imagine that the number is
much bigger of individuals drugs
and the sex trafficking that's taking
place and by the way these women and the
children are being abused along the
journey
and this is all coming at an enormous
price to the american taxpayer so it's
not fair
for anybody involved the only winners
here are the cartels and the smugglers
who are profiting
off these individuals could i ask you
then about that because there is a
report
that the white house is considering
making some direct payments to people
in those countries to help prevent them
from making a decision
to leave any thoughts on that
yeah typical democrat response to throw
more money
at a problem there was already a
solution here and it was the
prop the the issue the state of mexico
policy the agreements that president
trump made with the central american
countries
um he undid the he did all this and and
it's not just those central american
countries
the facility we visited had individuals
from over 60 countries represented
so this is a much larger criminal
operation
by the cartels that president president
biden has incentivized and he can simply
fix it today by undoing those executive
orders
and then look we can work toward common
sense uh
policies for immigration to streamline
and modernize the system but it has to
have entry exit visa tracking e-verify
you know you make some great points
congressman they need to do their job
congresswoman thank you so much for
joining us this morning we appreciate it